greetings Iron Man
welcome to the arrestee ax
[Music]
as beautiful as the day she launched
I've studied her blueprints extensively
one of your finest designs wonder if
they kept the Japanese tonight if you're
feeling nostalgic sir perhaps a quick
fly around sure let's take a trip down
memory lane very good sir I've marked
your HUD with some points of interest
[Music]
this Hangul wasn't designed for an
electromagnetic duel you know looks like
shield decided to go with the lowest
bidder on this one
what are how the turbines are holding up
[Music]
nice to see they upgraded to my mark 5
turbine engines they've added enhanced
shock mounts as well you make me so
proud vapor pneumatic anti-aircraft
cannons cloud busters first at their
kind you know your stuff
remember that at my next performance
review care for a game hey Nick I think
I'm already in one you're definitely
being played hard light makes these old
drones of yours extra hard to kill to me
which shield had something like that
imagine the possibilities maybe the
ghost will sell it to you we don't buy
tech from terrorists suppose we could
pirate it that would justify the
eyepatch
why'd you stop selling weapons to me
I needed to sleep better needed to sleep
better
Tony I got it
[Music]
in one basket ghost I see you've built a
giant cage where do you find the time
you will have to give me their number
[Music]
[Music]
neck where's the air support all my Jets
are boxed in the ghost pack the hangar
doors shut copy that
I'll turn them loose sir that could
leave you vulnerable to the attacking
drones sure but if I don't do it Nikhil
go full fury on sir ahead immediately to
the hangar doors let's release those
Jets the locking clamps need to be
manually opened grab the handle and pull
to release it
these are hammer industries locks how
the hell can you tell I've got a history
of destroying their catalog
elbow grease is all it takes rook 1 and
Bishop your favorite takeoff Roger
thanks Iron Man
[Music]
Friday the update on how to take down
this cage still evaluating sir
Tony we've detected explosive devices
inside the Helicarrier our ghosts been
busy Friday give me a location on those
bombs
marking them on your heart
[Music]
sensing a trend
the nodes at each end supply power to
the core a blast of refrigerant to each
load should do the trick put these bonds
on ice cold hands warm heart working
the explosive core is inert remove the
extra two to go
at least give me a fighting chance ghost
to shun get a fighting chance again no
idea who that is
right now don't care detecting a
knowledge energy spike sir
multiple attack vectors on radar or they
don't know when to quit
they take after their maker throw
everything you got at them Nick let's
end
it's an all-out assault
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
ready to go
[Music]
[Music]
that gets the arc reactor company sir my
scan of the laser cage is complete those
spheres generate energy for the entire
structure but they're protected against
all forms of conventional firepower
let's get unconventional an EMP from a
shield Jets Thunderbolt missile could
render the node susceptible to your most
favorite weapon my fists indeed get
within stunning range of the spheres and
are sent targeting information to shield
[Music]
target information sent thunderbolt
missiles away get inside the node and
punch the courser
[Music]
what note to go
he wants a needle she'll probably give
your metal player actions today stuck
probably come to the ceremony it'd be
good to get some face time with you
ghost
target information sent thunderbolt
missiles away
down for the cats punch-drunk sir
as mr. Hogan might say
good job Tony it's like those
Thunderbolt missions really came through
here he goes
imagine the mess we'd be in you've never
sold it if I never sold anything to
anyone none of us would be in this mess
in the first place
thanks for the help to keep that metal
head of yours out of trouble where's the
fun in that Mac until next time
[Music]
you
you